there's 396 now before we actually just
look at the answer i want to point out i
said this before but i want to
re-emphasize it it was super fire right
it's a bit of a mean almost anything
word in different contexts simplified
means do different things I think most
people look at this and instinctively
said okay if I can take something out of
this 96 if I can take some square root
out of there then that will be simpler
and what is the square root has been
packing out in order to know that 16
because 96 is 6 times 6 10 so you take
up the square root of sixteen the square
root of 16 in all three times four is
twelve is employment right the square
root of sick like even though this
number in the front is bigger honey this
guy be smaller is more valuable right
having the number under the square root
is more valuable than having a small
monthly fee arm and a perfect in every
way is puppet and look you can see here
i would go to line up working here which
is very very helpful do you agree with
that line of work yeah yes so you can
see you've taken out through 29 and then
taken up the square root 16 which gives
you be excited once you do that once you
make the third part of it as small as
possible only then can you identify when
actually even though they look different
there's really talk in the same language
and then you can signify does that make
sense so that's why we say it's better
yet this number as small as you possibly
can just like if you have fractions
devil
sorry you could add these without
changing what these fractions look like
but clearly it's simpler if we convert
these to decriminalize where the
denominator is a little box right that's
easier work with and it's the same deal
with all of this right on top of your
question 23 a plus-12 breathing yes now
why is am I see why there's a 380 why is
it 12 where did that come from yeah
that's three if they applied to
everything inside the bracket if I had
more thing 50 like a plus 4 plus X plus
PI plus whatever you like everything
gets multiplied by 3 that's what the
bracket draw ok have a look cute we have
no we don't have a lot of working so
before this way mere SAR what's the line
you can put straight up to this what
language contraction and you want to
hand up I'll give you a clue it starts
with one leg my boy right yes and you're
putting by Finance TX okay now you're
going to be really careful here right
we've got a 225 and that does give you
10 what it's not just too it's a and
this is an easy mistake that we won for
your attention to it it easier to just
say oh yeah I don't do that and you
expand it just like this guy so 2x plus
10 is a column think to make this
composition but now you notice actually
it minus 2 times all these things so it
should be one of our done before this
line it's actually one minus 2x minus
10c you agree with that does that equal
minus 2x by design
yeah because right you're collecting
like terms the one and the minus ten you
can put them together which is what you
get you all right now lock 1 C squared
plus 49 you swear that you get this when
you square that you get 49 what do you
think now think is actually missing a
tiny thing on the end and so it suggests
to me what is it missing any takers yeah
ok so this pair of numbers here not only
do they get squared independently on
their own both bit too right but in
addition to that they actually interact
with each other let me convince you ok
firstly under thinking out on its 14 20
case you're wondering when you drive
along ok 2 plus 7 or square that's
shorthand right because ultimate a smart
decision we love to be as concise as
possible but in longhand it might give
it easier to see maybe you want to write
it now with me Sid my seven all squared
around reddit is c plus 7 times c plus
seven feel great that's fine right now
what you do with it is just like what
you did with this right if you got
everything in a bracket for example this
see applies to everything in here but
this seven also applies everything here
right so if i just go turn my fam three
times c which is which is exactly what
exactly right i really like what else we
got here same time seven
okay so I've done this one again both of
those so far so good but you can see I
haven't talked about I'm not going to
stack i dint see that i'm going to the
same thing with this guy i'm going to
this so 7 10 feet and now you can see
whether 14c control see where it's
something else + 49 you're great and
then these to collect to be that is what
I'm a quick way to you can convince your
photo you've seen as before I'm c + 7 or
squared we call it square because you
can pour it with the plan right let me
show you what c + 7 or square would look
like c + 7 c hired a seven-part done
okay these past seven parts like that
you agree at 60 shop is c plus 7 squared
that ok ok with seat web it's the big
one over here whens 49 it's a little
ones over here but of course you're
missing servin see here and 70 gr like
that right so that's why you always if
it's actually hang around here you can
go with us you're done